i have to say
first of all that the idea of a
post-pandemic series about a sickness
that wipes out
people was not really something that i
thought that i wanted to watch
but i watched the show i got completely
hooked i fell in love with it
and you even made me cry more than once
so oh
christian what was it that made you fall
in love with sweet tooth
the fact that it's a completely
new and unique plot that i've never
even could have conceptualized in my
head before like
there was half animal
half kid kids that were being
born while at the same time there is a
virus that is
devastating the world but it's also a
tale of
two friendships well um it's actually a
tale
of everyone in the world trying to
cure the virus and eliminating hybrids
and jeopards trying to save gus and gus
is trying to save everyone so i mean
well all i'm gonna say is that it's a
big action-packed dystopian adventure
that it is well nancy what what was the
moment for you when you realized just
how
magical and special this story and this
show is
i think the moment for me when i
realized how magical and special this
show is when
um we
actually watched the second
i think this we didn't watch the fight
we watched the first and second episode
together
i think we had an early screening and
um it was still there wasn't everything
wasn't completed there was a lot of
you know cgi need to go in things that
need to to be included
but i got to sit down and watch it with
the rest of the
cast and crew it was kind of a treat for
us as we were coming to an end
and that's when i realized just how
magical it was
but also filming there in new zealand
it's just a magical
landscape i mean it's a beautiful
country
and like genuinely genuinely is true
there's nowhere like it on earth
um the south island in in new zealand
is um is untouched and it's almost
prehistoric in nature you see
plants and trees that you don't normally
see so that's
that's the time when i found it yeah
amazing and like nuns are saying
new zealand's so surreal and prehistoric
and
you know being there in new zealand
really does make
the show of you know a magical wonderful
fairy tale and dystopian world really
come alive
these two cannot be a more unlikely
pairing which
is part of what makes them so fun to
watch together
what do you enjoy about the relationship
between your characters
and what did you enjoy about working
with each other
okay so i really enjoyed the
relationship
between our characters because well
come on think about it a poacher who's
intended to kill
gus actually teams up with him
and helps him and go out on an adventure
together and there are the complete
opposites of each other
like like complete opposite
just seeing them go together on one big
adventure
is a really funny and cool experience
yeah i think that's ultimately you know
when there's juxtaposition when there
are layers to the character when you
have to find
the relationship between the characters
and convey that
in a believable but in a fantasy kind of
genre
and a storytelling kind of mode i really
feel like
that's an amazing challenge and as an
actor that's what it really attracted me
to it
um you know i i really i really feel
like offset
our relationship what i liked about
filming this is that we had a
relationship
offset as well christian's mom lisa is
off
just off screen there somewhere she
slides off screen but
she um did a really great job of
um bringing the cast together off offset
we would go to poetry um uh we do
protocols
yeah so uh we did pottery we did like an
art class we went to dinner a lot so we
we hung out a lot offset which isn't
very
isn't very common on a lot of a lot of
jobs um
but we did and and it really you know
bled out onto the screen and that's one
of the things people keep on mentioning
the most is that you know our
relationship the chemistry might not
have been there but it was because of
that
everything is left with big question
marks at the end of the season so
clearly we all need a second season
what are there things that you really
hope to see with your character
if there is a season two do you have
your own personal wish list for these
two
so fingers crossed if there's a season
two i already have like a whole plot in
my head of what might happen
so in my head based off some parts of
the comic book
and my imagination what i'd say is that
amy and jeopard go and rescue the
hybrids
together they also rescue dr singh and
his wife
ronnie and then together they take down
abbott
and then go and find birdie and then
maybe just encounter a new enemy
um well how do you feel about this plan
that christian has
that sounds that sounds interesting
that's how it sounds like it's a
it's a possibility that can happen i i'm
i i imagine that
um jeopard is really pissed and he wants
to
to get back at general albert so i um
and and get to set these kids free
um so i know that you know hopefully if
we do get a second season please netflix
um that we will um move
into that kind of storytelling mode
where that story gets told because you
can see
the last time you saw my character and
amy
in that room um we were like we're about
to kick some butt
do you hope that the jeopard's child is
still alive and that
we'll get to meet him oh
that's an interesting
maybe he's one of the hybrids in the
prisoner
we don't know that was the impression
that i had so that would be something i
think would be really cool to get that
would be cool
that would certainly be really cool yeah
that would be cool i mean you know
that we have to see we have to wait we
we haven't even filmed it yet so we
don't know
but it would be very cool it would be
very cool
well i appreciate you guys talking to me
i love this
it seems like there's so many ways that
could have gone wrong and it's so
beautiful and magical and i loved every
second of it so
thank you thank you so much thank you